Al momento de ocupar el cargo fue la
jefa de gobierno más joven del mundo a
sus 34 años la socialdemócrata sana
Marín tomó las riendas del ejecutivo de
Finlandia con una de las pruebas más
difíciles de los últimos años para
cualquier gobierno la pandemia del Coby
su gestión hizo que el país fuera una de
las Naciones menos afectadas y de las
primeras en aliviar las restricciones de
prevención
Finlandia es capaz de alejarse
gradualmente y de manera controlada de
las restricciones hacia un control
epidémico más fuerte
los Ecos de la pandemia no dejaban de
resonar cuando Rusia invadió el
territorio ucraniano además de ser una
de las críticas más fuertes del kremlin
a sana Marín no le tembló la mano para
responder a las acciones rusas la
primera ministra firmó una solicitud
para unirse al otan luego de 80 años de
neutralidad militar creo que es el
interés de todos que los diferentes
países se muevan lo más rápido posible
esa sería la mejor garantía de seguridad
que podríamos tener en 2020 eligió a
Marín como una de las mujeres más
influyentes del mundo incluso Time la
colocó en una de sus portadas en 2021
pero un año después la filtración de
imágenes suyas en varias fiestas
privadas dio la vuelta al mundo
despertando críticas
soy humana
y a veces también extraño la alegría la
luz y la diversión en medio de estas
nubes oscuras
sus principales opositores como los
partidos de derecha y extrema derecha la
culpan de aumentar la deuda y Por ende
de poner en peligro el modelo de
bienestar finlandés